i'm chantal i'm a retired physician
and i'm a moon gardener
[Music]
luna gardening is something that's been
going on for centuries
farmers have developed it but it's
become more of a
quote-unquote science i started planting
according to the lunar cycles
i have found that by putting it into
practice things grow much faster
than they would otherwise and i think
what it's got to do
is that to do with putting yourself in
sync
with the rhythms of the seasons and the
rhythms of the earth
and the rhythms of planting and i think
that
when you put yourself in sync with the
seasons when you're in touch with nature
you feel different you are more grounded
it's a different feeling and i think
that that's what
permeates this garden as a result of the
fact that
this garden is on a street corner
there's a lot
of foot traffic around it i don't have a
fence
so it doesn't make any sense for me to
try to keep things to myself
so it was almost out of necessity
that i created a garden that's open to
the community
this just happens to be where i can
garden so i'm gardening
out front that necessity
pulled me out of myself it pulled me out
of my depression it put me back in touch
with the community
and now a lot of different things have
grown out of it
i put out this little stand which has
become
an exchange when i have excess produce i
put it in there people can pick it up
when people have excess stuff from the
neighborhood
they'll come in they'll put it there and
you know it's just a really nice way for
people to share
what they've got
[Music]
started the garden on this little plot
right here which is about i think
10 by 20 feet and that was the very
first
garden everything else when i started
gardening
was lawn except for just a little border
over here and when i first started
gardening
it was not really in my mind to do
anything other than
just to plant a few flowers and to have
a pretty garden
but the real urge to garden
and this particular garden
came about after i got really sick
i hurt my back and had a couple of
spine operations and
the recovery was very very difficult and
long i was on a lot of medication became
very very depressed
and just found really
a very hard time motivating myself to do
anything
i had so much pain i couldn't stand for
very long to do anything inside the
house it was hard to imagine that i
could even
do anything outside but i had this
urge it was like a
elemental force that said come and do
this
you can do this i didn't listen at first
because it seemed
impossible when i couldn't stand up to
cook a meal
how was i gonna you know come out and
build a garden but that voice wouldn't
stop it just said yeah you can do this
you can just come out and garden one day
i remember that i had this little stool
that rolled around and i put
on my back brace and i slipped an ice
pack in
in the back here and i came out and
before i knew it i had cleared up the
space
and within a few days i had actually i
planted my very first garden and i got
enough vegetables
out of that very first garden to share
with a lot of people
and that's what got me going
this part is the herb garden and
i always tell my students if you're
going to have an herb garden you must
put it
really really close to the to your front
door
it has to be just within a few steps so
that when you want something
you can walk out clip it and walk back
inside so i've got parsley oregano
all of my culinary herbs but i also grow
some medicinal herbs i've got lemon balm
i've got lemon verbena
feverfew and i like to make my own soaps
and i make my own
creams and lotions so i use the herbs
and the flowers from the garden to
infuse
oils and then from those oils i make
the different products and i use there's
a that's pretty much what we use for the
whole family
i make enough so that i can ship out to
the whole to
to my family at christmas time and
that's my christmas gifts
lavender is one of my favorite plants
it's one of my favorite scents
i think it's really calming if you've
got any kind of anxiety you want to have
lavender growing in your garden and
certainly
as a stress believer it's just a
wonderful scent
this is french lavender and i propagated
it and
grew a whole hedge out of that one plant
it's one of the things i taught during
the class
i specifically created a path
from one side to the other to encourage
people
to come through the garden and to wander
and to cut through
and to sit down if they wish i have
a lot of fruit trees growing this is my
guava tree and you can see some guavas
we'll have gonna be making guava jelly
this year
this is a satsuma tangerine
that's a mango tree right there
gave some beautiful mangoes and
there's a cherry moya tree a couple of
pear trees
and plum and nectarine
i've always got kale growing and i like
to keep the kale right
in front because i encourage people to
pick it themselves and the kids love to
come by
and pull the kale and just chew on it
this is my
vegetable exchange stand
people will bring things that they have
extras of and whenever i have any extras
i'll put it in there
and whatever is there the the
neighborhood
partakes i have a few more beans growing
so this was loaded up with beans you can
see they're really drying up and i've
left them on the on the vine
to dry up because i want the seeds
for next year so i don't have to go and
buy any more seeds i just collect the
dry seed pods yeah you wait till they're
completely dry
and then i will use those seeds for my
next year's crop
happy and that little thing that little
pole
with the can at the top that's where i
put peanuts for my friend
blue jay and he comes and eats the
peanuts but he stays around and eats the
bugs too
so i encourage him to visit the garden
because that's my pest control
i've got bird feeders hanging all
through the garden
for that's for the same reason because
you bring the birds to your garden
they will help you out by eating eating
the insects
today with the children of the
neighborhood we planted the box
and this is our winter vegetable box so
we planted
kale lettuce
broccoli onions
there's cauliflower and there are
flowers growing to attract beneficial
insects all throughout the bugs
at the bottom it's full of logs so it's
called a hugel culture
because it's very expensive to fill a
box with
a lot of soil and you can get away by
putting a bunch of
twigs and grasses and everything at the
bottom
yeah put about four inches of soil and
that's all you need to grow
and as things go along the branches will
decompose and actually
rot and turn into soil so that's what's
going on with this box
we planted a bunch of trees along the
parkway now that we have
gotten permission to grow food on the
parkways
so i've got citrus growing on the
parkway
the the outside of the garden is not
irrigated
at all and only depends on
whether i water it or or the weather
waters it
and that's because it's meant to be a
permaculture garden so it should not
really depend
on watering it's it's hard to maintain
at first
but once you get it going you just have
absolutely no worries it just keeps
itself going so
um it may not be
obvious to put roses but roses are
actually really hardy
they are drought tolerant and they will
reward you with the profusion of flowers
whenever it starts to rain again so
i find them good plants to intersperse
these are my favorite roses and i plant
roses in remembrance of people
so you know when i
lose a friend or a family
relative i will plant a rose bush
in so there's a roseburg this is my
aunt's rose bush
she likes yellow roses and there's one
planted for my mother
so yeah this is my way of keeping their
memory alive
i have one more plant that in terms of
memory and keeping things alive is
really important to me that i'd like to
show you
so it's up over here and it's right by
my door
it's not a very showy plant at all it
doesn't look
fabulous but it
means a lot okay so this aloe plant
was given to me as a gift from a family
that has preserved it since the middle
passage
this particular plant made it
through the middle passage was smuggled
aboard ship
by a slave it was grown
in the fields of america that family
escaped to freedom
to canada they took the plant with them
and grew it over there
some of them came back to the united
states they came to maryland they
brought the plant to maryland
and some of them moved to not too far
from here
a few blocks away from here and i was
lucky enough
to get a piece of it we don't have very
many things to connect
us to our past there's a big block
that's you know been taken away from us
and
to have anything that you can touch
that carries the memory of your
ancestors
be there not even blood related
to me is this is my talisman it's it's
amazing to have this
it's just amazing i take my inspirations
from some people that i really admire
vandana shiva is one of my heroes
she started the seed saving movement in
northern india
after the epidemic of pharma suicides up
there
and she has been a real force
against monsanto she established
an organization that has
really revitalized seed saving
and heirloom seeds in india and
really it's an amazing woman
so she's one of my uh inspirations she
says that to
to garden to produce your own food
is a revolutionary act because right now
we are so
enslaved by
our systems our food production systems
the way that
they've been set up um there's very
there's not enough response
to demand and our food
you know is shipped from all over the
place so all
you don't know what's on it you don't
know what pesticides are on it
what preservatives half the time it's
been picked before it's ripe and it's
been
you know subjected to gas
in order to ripen it artificially
it's not real nutritious food
and it's really really important i think
to everyone to get their hands in the
dirt
and to get back to growing something
whatever it is on your balcony wherever
you can find
some open space a little bit of sunshine
grow something
it'll make you better it'll make your
life better
[Music]